time to nut up or shut up people exam B
lad
you'll get why I started off with that
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey I am
thrilled to present this following video
to you guys
Sony Pictures and our friends over at
think Jam invited us to an event that
once we heard what was involved we were
like hell yeah we're going they gave us
the opportunity to interview the
screenwriters of Zombieland one in
Zombieland
double tap they're also the screen
riders for Deadpool one in Deadpool two
these guys are Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick we both really admire their work
a lot so once we were told we had a
chance to have a one-on-one interview
with them we were like yeah we'd love to
go so we agreed to it and then when we
got on a bus from the Sony Pictures lot
to go there
I didn't properly read through
everything that was gonna go on at the
event best waited there cuz I was like I
just want to interview them come to find
out we're going to Angel Stadium and
we're going to also do this Monster Jam
event where they're gonna have us go
inside of the gravedigger truck they're
gonna have a GoPro set up in there we're
gonna get a ride around in the dirt
never been to a monster truck event
definitely ever been inside of a monster
truck it was a really fun time you
follow us on Instagram we did a lot of
Instagram stories there were so many
other influencers that are people like
John wrote dead meet James Winston from
the movie trivia Schmo down those etc'
boys whole lot of people the event in
and of itself was a total blast I did an
Instagram live video when we were in the
monster truck so the footage I'm going
to show you is cutting back and forth
between the GoPro they had set up there
in the Instagram live video and then
right after that gonna show you guys the
interview that we had Wood Rhett Reese
and Paul Wernick they were so courteous
so kind everyone at this event was so
professional the standard we expect at
every level when it comes to the real
rejects the professional car in monster
truck
and that's what we're gonna be riding in
right there but of course because it was
a special event they hooked up some
goodies which is the main thing we go to
anything for Zombieland double tap which
is now available on blu-ray 4k Ultra HD
digital and DVD and you could probably
rent it off some streaming service
somewhere I'm excited to own this
because if you guys saw our review which
we did months before we were ever even
invited to this we were both very
enthusiastic about Zombieland double tap
genuinely really really enjoyed the
movie we liked the film for free and
then they also gave us these other fun
toys this monster Jam's zombie helmet
how cool is that as an actual
gravedigger that we wrote in life-size
monstrous so guys pick yourself up a
copy of zombie land double tap thank you
think jam and sony pictures once again
enjoy the video sup guys this is how
desperate we are to get you to watch
zombie land right now we're in a monster
truck Monster Jam we just met there's a
lot of us live we want to see who's
gonna get the most views do oh sure we
should wear seatbelts for sure
let's me don't you wish that on me
everyone party live reaction here with
what's up guys okay I want everyone we
got I got fifteen eyes how many eyes
have you got I mean it won't stop me for
some reason which is fine that's more
than Ricky Ali wrote that you're a
monster Roca
[Applause]
what's that
wait what Zombieland double tap now
[Applause]
[Music]
- up left guys got a wife before
it's late I'm Greg Alba and I'm John
Humphrey
we're with the real rejects
we're seriously like major fans of while
you guys were a major major fans and we
said in our review like months ago that
we prefer Zombieland to over the first
one oh that's a long time thank you very
much so our first question ten years
after the first Zombieland movie do you
guys think superhero movies are cinema
[Laughter]
my favorite movie of the last decade was
the Avengers so it's like I'm so that is
cinema that's an I don't care what I
don't care what Martin says we were
hoping we could catch them darn it darn
it yeah
did you just cut a little more off your
chair right completely genuine though I
wanted to ask you guys do so much worth
together what is the general collab
process like on a first draft for
example first script I mean you guys
take turns one word at a time what we do
is sit around in a room and break story
together we have a big cork board with
cards and you know kick around ideas and
that can take anywhere from two weeks to
three months yeah depending on how the
ideas are flowing and and how we're
feeling and then we break it down into
an outline and you know this is getting
very specific but I damn please
and then basically divvy up scenes and
we go off and run each right in our own
writing spaces and and and then trade
scenes back and forth to rewrite each
other it's a little like a puzzle piece
it's sort of like a quilt that slowly
comes together over time yeah and it and
it works strangely like it cuz you think
the best idea maybe but but it does work
for us so it seems to be flowing pretty
well so over that amount of time did you
go through a bunch of court board's
because it's been so long since the
first movie like I think we still have
the original wrong
it comes down it's the same corkboard
but then that the cards get stack and
it's like oh my god we had four or five
versions of these these stacks of cards
and just make it reads like months what
the worst thing about a project is is if
you're developing a project then you
have to kind of start over like well I
got [ __ ] it doesn't work we got to go
back to the board you go back to the
board you pull out the board and the
cards from the previous outliner still
in the eye and then you go in that
morning like I love that scene
apparently sucks so did you guys find
that the writing process for this one
specifically was a little bit easier
because you knew the voices of the
actors in mind it's funny that the
characters writing the voice of the
characters was easier finding the story
was a little bit harder because it was
that ten-year passage and a lot had
happened
off-camera to account you know during
those ten years so so the actual
characters writing them in their voice
and who they are and how they interact
easy you know the journey they're taking
was a little bit more difficult for us
on this one our last question with that
in mind when you would develop the plot
for this do you start with the
characters motivations first or like
where they might be or do you look at
the plot first and then fill in the
character arcs there oh gosh I think
it's sort of each feeds the other that's
a bad answer so ask Anna you can ask
another question but I think it's really
cyclical with plot feats character
character feeds broad so it's reader is
sort of like chicken made but they I
wouldn't say one drives the other
necessarily so you get another question
I don't want to have and on that crappy
answer did you find yourselves having to
adjust a lot since so many other big
profile zombie shows and movies have
come since Amba that's funny we kind of
ignored all of them you know
and and it just did our own thing ours
felt unique in the sense of the you know
action comedy you know and you know it
sets its set apart from from The Walking
Dead and that it definitely super
serious and it's awesome but and but
like we couldn't out Walking Dead The
Walking yeah so there was no reason for
us to have really evil human characters
or zombies that were absolutely
terrifying we're always leaning into the
comedy the wish-fulfillment the escapism
so the heart - yeah the heart and so we
at the end of the day we didn't really
feel like we were competing with those
other things we kind of kind of keep
them at the periphery and just try to do
what we do well thank you guys so much
you